[Musique]
via la solidarité est du type ii italia
comment se fait-il que je me sente ici à
vole une aiguille émotionnelle pirate du
médecine du guana au monde et à la personne qui
c'est vraiment nécessaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les chercheurs des professeurs arrivent
faculté de médecine qui ont fréquenté
première ligne dès le premier instant
à l'épicentre et il est donc important
l'échange d'expériences avec les nôtres
chercheurs de première ligne dans le
lutter contre le coronavirus donc aussi
c'est une attention à ceux qui
recherchez l'activité pour obtenir le
le plus tôt possible pour vaincre cela
costume rouge si agressif
[Musique]